Zac Goldsmith has been chosen as the
conservative candidate for the 2016
London mayoral lecture and he was the
obvious choice compared to side come out
Stephen greenhalgh and Andrew Boff who
are the other candidates in the running
Zack was the bookies favorite from the
beginning to be the Tories candidate and
he's the one who's most likely to win
next May now obviously Zack is very
different from Boris Johnson who he is
replacing and he certainly got a
challenge because London is
fundamentally a Labour City the voters
are inclined to back labour see he's got
to convince them to go against their
instincts and back the Tories
Saxe got a pretty good chance of being
the next mayor of London he's got a bit
of that x-factor which is something a
Tory needs to win in London he's also
very thoughtful he's got a natural charm
he's very eloquent in the way he speaks
but he does have a slight issue these
quiet laid-back and doesn't have the vim
and vigor of Boris and I think voters
might be a bit surprised when they see
the two onstage contrasting each other I
think if he finds that locket to give
him that extra energy and there's a very
good chance he could do well in debate
it could convince London that another
old Italian is just what it needs
a Siddiq should be worried there has
been some polling that came out that
suggested that Sadiq could be
Zac but a lot changed since then not
least the election of Jeremy Corbyn as
Labour leader and I think a lot of
people won't go anywhere near the Labour
Party while Jeremy Corbyn is leading it
so I think Sadiq should be worried in
that sense but he has got the trade
unions on their side with their
activists and their money in their
support network while all Zac Goldsmith
has got is the aging ohtori machine but
there are rumors going around that Zac
has got Linton Crosby's firms CTF on
board if that's the case they can run
Boris a strategy of targeting the outer
London suburbs while letting Sadiq focus
on inner London if that works it could
be a very tight race and at this point
it's hard to say who is going to win